not everybody's meant to be a
communicator but I would like
universities to start paying more
attention and that make sure that every
area of physics there's at least one
person that gets coaching and gets the
opportunity to go out and explain it I
think it's important they have to
understand the scientific process why
things take so long and so this is where
I think we have to get out and start
explaining the process explaining the
time scales explaining all of these
things there are certain areas of
Science and in physics it's Astro that
you can ually get people out for public
talks because the public is willing to
come they also get the experience of
learning how to give public talks and
most science students do not get that
training